god help us
when i think about my dad growing up i
certainly think about that seriousness
and wanting to do the right thing
at the same time very few people get to
see
he's funny
weird and really playful you can't take
everything seriously because then you'll
start thinking that you're something
that you're not
i loved clinical medicine the idea of
discovery and having an impact on people
that's what really captured me
i grew up in a somewhat tough
neighborhood in brooklyn the culture is
that you didn't get intimidated by a lot
of things
when someone attacks i don't immediately
fight back it's nothing personal
strictly business
in 1981 hiv aids was evolving rapidly
and frighteningly there was anger at the
response we accused tony of causing
those deaths finally i put myself into
their shoes
that's when i started to really reach
out it was pretty much the first and
only time i think anybody in government
came to us that changed everything
when you got sick you were gone fast it
was so frustrating when you're used to
fixing things and you're just not really
fixing anything
it's affecting you now yeah
why
um
post-traumatic stress syndrome
when coveted hit he became this target
my dad said we're gonna get through this
whole thing and he's held that we're
seeing upticks again and nobody's
hearing from you
i don't understand the hate that people
have these people are really really
getting bad i mean you know they're
harassing my daughters constantly which
bothers me more than anything else we
heard about what he went through in the
hiv aids pandemic like seeing signs that
she's a murderer and i remember asking
him like is this actually what it was
like his response was you can't even
compare the two this is so beyond the
beyond apache says here are the facts
and here's my recommendation for a way
forward he becomes the size of the
challenge he faces each time if you're
the public servant you don't do it
because you want to make money you don't
do it for the glory you do it because
you care when you're involved in a race
to stop a horrible disease
you always feel you're not doing things
quickly enough
[Music]